Alan titford stand up
for the gross negligence manslaughter of
Kaylee titford I sentence you to seven
years six months imprisonment you will
serve two-thirds of the sentence namely
five years in custody before you are
released on license when you are
released you will be on license until
the end of this sentence
you must comply with the terms of the
license and commit no further offense or
else you will be liable to serve a
further period in custody
you may go down
for the gross negligence manslaughter of
Kaylee tipford having regard to your
guilty plea I sentence you to six years
imprisonment you will serve two-thirds
of the sentence namely four years in
custody before you are released on
license when you are released you will
be on license until the end of your
sentence you must comply with the terms
of the license and commit no further
offense or else you'll be liable to
serve a further period in custody
you may go down